what guy wouldn't want to be the
galaxy's most Cavalier and charming
rogue well the list for the potential
next scavenger hero has been narrowed
down I'm Dave and welcome to your
gamespot news update the list of actors
considered for the role of playing a
young han Solo has been narrowed down to
around a dozen names this according to a
new report from variety among the
remaining candidates being considered by
Disney and Lucasfilm are miles teller
from whiplash angel Elgort from
insurgent and the fault in our stars
dave Franco from 21 Jump Street Jack
reynor from transformers age of
extinction Scott Eastwood from gran
torino and fury logan lerman from 310 to
yuma and fury Emory Cohen from Brooklyn
and the place beyond the pines and Blake
Jenner from Glee apparently thousands of
actors were seen raging in the age of 17
to 34 for the starring role in a Star
Wars spin-off centered around the
exploits of a young han Solo filming for
the 2018 movie is still a year away but
decision can be made in the next month
as solo could appear in this year's Star
Wars spin-off rogue one a Star Wars
story that movie the first in Star Wars
anthology series comes out in December
and is set between episodes 3 and 4 the
Han Solo prequel does not yet have a
name but it does have a release date May
twenty-fifth 2018 that puts it almost
exactly a year after episode 8 which is
slated for May 26 2017 and will be
followed by episode 9 in 2019 there are
also reports of a movie starring Boba
Fett coming in 2020 but that remains
unconfirmed so who do you think the
perfect new Han Solo should be let us
know in the comments section below or
you can find me on Twitter at a regular
Dave and for all the Star Wars news from
a website not so far far away keep tuned
in to games.com